el papá francisco sorprendió al mundo
con una entrevista para un documental
que se estrenó este miércoles en el
festival de cine de roma en el cual el
pontífice expresa un apoyo inédito a las
uniones civiles de parejas del mismo
sexo las personas homosexuales dice
francisco tienen derecho a una familia
lo que tenemos que hacer es una ley de
convivencia civil tienen derecho a estar
cubiertos legalmente palabras explícitas
las del pontífice son los comentarios
más contundentes que un papá haya
pronunciado jamás en favor de las
uniones civiles de homosexuales y
claramente esto marca un distanciamiento
con respecto a la postura oficial de la
iglesia católica recordemos que la
doctrina católica considera los actos
homosexuales como un trastorno como
intrínsecamente desordenados esto según
el catecismo el católico entonces estas
palabras de francisco son significativas
y seguramente despertarán polémicas y
críticas por parte del ala
ultraconservadora de la iglesia católica